faire pousser une variété de fruits et
légumes à 200 km au nord du cercle
polaire arctique ça peut sembler
improbable et pourtant c'est une réalité
depuis plus de 20 ans grâce à une serre
chauffée par le soleil l'histoire se
passe à innovic une petite communauté
d'appels 3000 habitants dans les
Territoires du Nord-Ouest
[Musique]
cours la serre était l'Arena de
pensionnat autochtones
anglicates et catholiques venaient jouer
au hockey
quand ils ont annoncé qu'ils allaient
démolir le pensionnat le dernier au
Canada d'ailleurs il planifiait aussi de
démolir l'Arena lorsqu'on conduisait
devant l'édifice un ami et moi on a eu
une inspiration on s'est dit waouh ça
ferait une serre incroyable on a donc
formé une organisation mobiliser une
équipe et fait des demandes de
subvention
[Musique]
à l'époque j'ai fait une entrevue à la
radio de Radio-Canada yellow knife le
journaliste m'a dit Peter je veux bien
comprendre vous êtes en haut du cercle
polaire le soleil n'a pas brillé depuis
un mois il fait moins 35 dehors et vous
construisez une serre à innovic j'ai dit
oui c'est exactement ça et c'était le
commencement
elle était 1999 on faisait pousser des
légumes dans la serre
ce qui fantastique c'est que ça double
notre saison de culture on peut planter
à la mi-mai ce qui est deux semaines
plus tôt qu'en Alberta ensuite les
cultures sont à l'abri du gel jusqu'à la
fin septembre grâce à l'effet de serre
même si le soleil ne brille qu'une fois
ou trois jours par exemple on accumule
assez de chaleur
au début même s'il y a deux pieds de
neige dehors on est prêt à planter dans
la serre même s'il fait moins 10 ou
moins 15 dehors on rentre dans la serre
et c'est un peu comme un oasis dans
l'Arctique
[Musique]
en ce moment juin tout est vert mais à
la mi-juillet ce sera en pleine
croissance il y a des fraises des
tomates on a deux des pommiers les plus
nordiques au Canada on fait des belles
récoltes de pommes l'équipe de la serre
fait des tartes et on peut même en
vendre mais je suis certain que ce sont
les premiers les plus
[Musique]
on fait face à plusieurs personnes qui
n'ont pas la vision plusieurs nous
disaient qu'on perdrait notre temps
qu'on devait juste faire des petites
serres à la maison pour faire des tests
mais on avait un groupe convaincu et on
voulait faire de cette patinoire une
serre
ce projet a été formidable et nous a
permis de former un point de
rassemblement pour la communauté on a
transformé quelque chose qui avait une
connotation négative l'Arena ne
pensionnat autochtone en quelque chose
de positif aujourd'hui des enfants des
années toute la communauté viennent
apprendre à jardiner et produisent des
légumes pour eux-mêmes
mais les légumes c'est presque
secondaire le vrai bénéfice de notre
projet c'est de rassembler les gens
chaque soir les citoyens nous visitent
partagent des histoires
c'est devenu une sorte de sainte
communautaire les légumes sont un
bénéfice secondaire
[Musique]
la plus grande fierté c'est que ce soit
devenu un milieu de rassemblement pour
notre communauté
[Musique]